so as well-orchestrated as the molar
report public relations campaign was by
Donald Trump and the people around him
there's more and more talk of
impeachment that's taking place now now
in the past I would have just done this
story and not given disclaimers but
because of the climate right now and
some of the stuff that's going on with
the right some of the stuff that's going
on with the left I feel like I need to
issue some disclaimers before we talk
about this disclaimer one being that
I've said for a long time I don't see
impeachment as the fastest way to get
rid of Trump it's gonna take longer than
just voting him out in 2020 at this
point even if you could actually get him
out quickly you aren't going to be able
to do it without Republican support and
that that is not something that there
appears to be there appears to be no
will at all and I've also pointed out
that impeachment is not a political
strategy for Democrats it wasn't won in
2018 it's not going to be a good one for
2020 so that's all of the sort of
disclaimers here but with all of that
being said there's no denying that
there's more momentum and discussion
about impeachment and that it has grown
significantly since the stunningly
damaging nature of the Moller report was
revealed last Thursday and one of the
important things to consider that really
is probably the most important
what could you impeach Donald Trump for
at this point in time he said before why
would you impeach a president that's
doing a great job that that's sort of
one cartoonishly ridiculous perspective
but here's another or there is another
at least and the other is now more than
ever that impeachment should be
seriously discussed and it's being
discussed by more and more democratic
elected officials and also more and more
media if you checked out yesterday
Sunday political talk shows there was a
ton of impeachment discussion senator
Elizabeth Warren is now straight up
saying impeachment proceedings should
start Congressman Jerry Nadler said
yesterday on Meet the Press that the
content of the Moller report contains
impeachable offenses check that out do
you think this is impeachable
yeah I do I do think that this that if
proven if proven which hasn't been
proven yet some of this if proven some
of this would be impeachable yes
obstruction of justice if proven would
be impeachable and you're gonna go about
to see if you can prove it well we're
gonna see where the facts lead us
congressman Elijah Cummings is putting
it in sort of different language saying
if Democrats don't do anything it will
just embolden Donald Trump which is true
although he's pretty emboldened at this
point in time but the point is is Trump
going to be allowed to get away with
this degree of wrongdoing Adam Schiff
says that the Moller report contains
impeachable offenses and congressman
Schiff let's turn to impeachment senator
Elizabeth Warren has tweeted the
severity of this misconduct demands that
elected officials in both parties set
aside political considerations and do
their constitutional duty that means the
house should initiate impeachment
proceedings against the President of the
United States you said unless there's
bipartisan support for it it is a bad
idea but what about that constitutional
duty or any precedent that this might
set well look I think Elizabeth Warren
makes an important point and that is
that the level of evidence in the mole
report is serious and damning and in a
normal circumstance would be I think
without question within the realm of
impeachable offenses we are
unfortunately an environment today with
the GOP leadership people like Kevin
McCarthy are willing to carry the
president's water no matter how corrupt
or unethical or dishonest the
president's conduct may be now if you've
watched this show for any length of time
you know that I have never called for
impeachment I've pointed out that I
believe it's not a winning strategy it's
not likely to succeed at this point
there are faster ways to get rid of the
President of the United States and I'm
still not calling for impeachment but
there is a real question right now of if
there are no consequences for this if
there aren't even
repercussions for what's in the molar
report including substantial evidence of
obstruction can a president ever be held
accountable in modern politics or will
the existence of this sort of 30 percent
immutable unchangeable base of support
and the political will that goes along
with it in our elected officials does
that mean that a president can never
face consequences because that's close
to where we are if we say despite all
the evidence despite what Muller said
for political reasons there are not
going to be consequences for Donald
Trump because remember molar is
explanation for not indicted the
president is 95% political he believed
it would hinder Trump's ability to be
President he was aware of the Justice
Department sort of tradition guidance
that you can indict or should not indict
a sitting president that's as close to
codifying the President as being above
the law
as is possible so I understand the
feeling from Democrats of exasperation
of knowing that they don't seem to be
able to get any Republican to care about
what the molar report exposes and what
has transpired and I understand the
feeling that hey are we are we just
letting trump get away with everything I
totally understand that the practical
reality is still that without
Republicans you're not doing anything as
far as impeachment goes and that it's
probably faster to just vote Trump out
in November of 2020 tomorrow on the show
I'm going to address this idea that
impeaching Trump is a bad idea because
Pence is worse which I have talked about
before my view on that has changed
significantly and I'm actually going to
address that on on tomorrow's program
but in the meantime I want to hear your
thoughts has your view on impeachment
changed as a result of the content of
the Muller probe if so how and how are
you now sort of feeling about it
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman if you've not
already heard about blink Asst it's
amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
15 minute audio book you get all the
most important information and insights
from each book but you can soak up the
entire essence of the book in one
sitting
I've listened to a ton of books on
blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n